donc voici mon fils marley quand il avait 19
ans, il a reçu une
balle dans la tête
assis dans une voiture avec un ami
je me suis toujours senti comme la suède
et où nous vivions en famille d'accueil était en sécurité
c'était un endroit sûr
[Musique]
bien  derrière nous juste ici, il y avait un
gars qui a été abattu dans la pizzeria, il a été
abattu par un jeune de 16 ans
qui est entré dans la pizzeria et portait un
masque facial et l'a abattu par derrière à
bout portant, puis à
100 mètres ici pour  à gauche il y avait
une autre personne qui avait 19 ans
qui a été abattue dans un
escalier
[Musique] [
Musique]
vous avez tout ici vous avez comme un
vieil allemand un pistolet Luger vous avez une
kalachnikov
nous avons même des grenades comme vous pouvez le voir
ici alors vous  avoir des armes plus modernes que
vous pouvez avoir comme euh
un glock par exemple vous avez
des armes d'europe de l'est vous avez des fusils de chasse
comme
un arsenal de comme tout
je n'ai jamais vu ces armes quand je suis devenu
policier en 2006.
et à partir de 2012 nous commençons à voir des gans
partout  de différents pays et
des grenades explosives
[Musique]
m
oh
toi